[موسيقى]
ال 8 بتوقيت جرينتش الحادي عشر بتوقيت
الرياضه وهذه اخبار الساعه
رغم التمديدات والتحذيرات طالبان تتحدى
منع الفتيات من التعليم والعمل وتقول لو
القوا علينا قنبله ذريه لن نتراجع
في العلن بوتين يخرج ورقه التفاوض وفي
السر يخطط لمسار العسكري جديد اكثر خطوره
في اوكرانيا
منها واليها شبح كورونا يعود للصين ويهدد
بموجه واسعه تضرب مئات الملايين
ومخوف من سيناري و2019
عواصف ثلجيه القاسيه تجمد الحياه في
امريكا كندا ودول الاوروبيه وتتسبب في
حاله فوضى في المطر
[موسيقى]
موقتنا اهلا بكم في اخبار الساعه لم يعد
للمراه في مكان في افغانستان تحت حكم
طالبان هذا ما فعلته الحركه منذ تواليها
السلطه في انتهاك كافه حقوق النساء وفرض
القيود عليهم بدايه من قيود اللباس
وحرمانهن من الترفيه ودخول الصلاه
الرياضيه ومن ثم المكتبات العامه والمعاهد
والاخضر حضر حقهن في التعليم الجامعي وفي
اخر القيود القاسيه على نساء منع الطالبان
المراه من العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
فيما وصف بانه خرق واضح للمبادئ الانسانيه
في افغانستان
[موسيقى]
قرارات طالبان هذه الاستهداف في حريات
النساء وقمعهن وصلبهن حقوقهن قوبلت بسخطه
دوليه واسع وفي احدث الردود على قرار
طالبان الاخير علقت 4 منظمات اجنبيه غير
حكوميه عملها في افغانستان بعد حظر النساء
فيها واقالت منظمه انقذ الاطفال والمجلس
النرويجي لللاجئين ومنظمه كير ولجنه
الانقاذ الدوليه انهم لا يستطيعون مواصله
اعمال الاغاثه والمساعدات الانسانيه بدون
موظفاتهم واعتبرت منظمه الصليب الاحمر الى
منع طالبان للنساء من التعليم والعمل في
الادوار الانسانيه يمكن ان يؤدي الى
عواقبه انسانيه كارثه من جانبها دعت وزيره
الخارجيه الالمانيه في تغريده لها الى
تبني رد فعل واضح من المجتمع الدولي بعد
قرارات طالبان القمعيه ضد النساء في ما دل
الاتحاد الاوروبي قرار طالبان معلنا انه
يقيم تداعيه ذلك على مساله تقديم
المساعدات لافغانستان
[موسيقى]
وفي مزيد من ردود الفعل الدوليه المهدده
بقرارات في طالبان نادى على الامين العام
ل- اا المنظمه منظمه التعاون الاسلاميه
حسين دع الحركه لاعاده النظر في قرار
تعليق عمل النساء في المنظمات غير
الحكوميه معبرا عن مخاوفه العميقه من
تداعيت هذا القرار
بين جانبه قال المتحدث الاقليميه باسم
الخارجيه الامريكيه صمويل في لقاء مع
العربيه قال ان حركات طالبه بقرارها منع
نساء من التوظيف في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
ستعطي نفسها عن الشعب الافغاني والمجتمع
الدولي مضيفا ان الولايات المتحده ستبحث
مع حلفائها للرد الانسب على طالبه كل هذه
القرارات فعلا تؤدي الى زياده الاصل طالما
من المجتمع الدولي ومن سكان اذن همم كما
قلت الان كما نرى في الافغانستان همم هذا
ليس ال ال ال السبب او ليس مسؤوليه للشعب
ولكن همم
هي التي تاخذ كل هذه القرارات المتحده
لدينا بعد الاليات واسمعنا منذ ايام من
وزير يمكن ان نحن الان سن الباحث مالهنا
والشركاؤنا بالنسبه
رساله واضحه
حول هذه القرارات
ووسط موجه التمديد الدوليه هذا رده طالبان
قبل قليل حيث قال المتحدث باسم طالبان ذبح
الله مجاهد ان الحركه ترفض اي تهديدنا على
خلفيه قراراتها المتعلقه بالنساء مضيفا
انا طالبان ترفض ايضا تدخل امريكا بشئونها
وفي المنظمات العامله في افغانستان
من جانبه قال وزير التعليم العالي بحكومه
طالبان نداء محمد نديم ان الحركه لن
تتراجع عن قراراتها تجاه النساء حتى ولو
القي عليهم قنبله ذريه واكد وزير التعليم
العالي بحكومه الطالبات ان الحركتها
مستعده للعقوبات التي قد تفرض عليها من
المجتمع الدولي مؤكدا انهم لن يقبلوا ما
وصفه بالاملاءات من اي شخص في ما يتعلق
بحقوق المراه
وتابع من كابول مع مراسلنا عبد الله نادر
عبدالله اهلا بك معنا المزيد حول ما قاله
ذبيح الله مجاهد في رده على الانتقادات
على طالبان بسبب اجراءاتها ضد النساء
نعم فقد كذب ذبيح الله مجاهد المتحدث باسم
طالبان في تغريده ردا على ما قاله مؤخرا
القائم باعمال السفاره الامريكيه في
افغانستان على المسؤولين الامريكيين عدم
تدخل في الشؤون الداخليه لبلدنا الاذاناته
تتوالى على طالبان لاتخاذها القرارات
الاخيره سواء كانت احيانا تعليم الفتيات
ومنعهن من مواصله الدراسه في الجامعات او
كانت حياه منعوا عمل السيدات في المنظمات
لغاتيه
المحليه والدوليه في وقت توقف عدد من
المنظمات فعالياتها احتجاجا على قرار
طالبان كم منظمه يبدا همم منظمه دي ار سي
الدينماركيه ومنظمه الترك
ما عدد النساء المتاثرات العاملات في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه في افغانستان
اللواتي فقدنا اعمالهم في هذه المؤسسات
حتى الان
هناك احصائيات محليه تقول بان ثلاثه الاف
سيده كنا يعملن في منظمه الانقاذ الدوليه
ار اي ار سي وحدها في وقت ليس لهن
وليساريهن الدخل الا رواتبهن وبحسب تعبيره
هؤلاء سيدات فانهن لا يستطيعن العيش بدون
مرتب شهري وليست هناك احصائيات دقيقه لكل
سيدات اللواتي كنا يعملن في جميع هذه
المؤسسات والمنظمات الخيريه والاغاثيه
المحليه والدوليه على الاقل اذا ما نعرف
حتى ثلاثه الاف امراه افغانيه كنا يعمل في
المنظمات غير الحكوميه فقدنا اعمالهم حتى
الان طيب ماذا عن الطالبات في الجامعات
عبد الله همم هل تم تطبيق القرار نهائيا
هل هناك اي حركات احتجاجيه من الطالبات
الجامعيات هل هناك اي تحرك مدني
نعم كانت هناك احتجاجات في بعض المدن
الكبرى كمقاطعه هيرات الغربيه وكذلك
مقاطعه النمروز ومقاطعه النينجرهان
الشرقيه وهذه الاحتجاجات قامت بها فتيات
الجامعات اللواتي تم حرمانههن من الدراسه
وكذلك هناك حملات على سوس الميديا ضد هذا
القرار ولحد الان هذا القرار حيز التنفيذي
وطالبان تصر على تنفيذه كما نفذ القرارات
الصارمه والصادمه للجميع همم
السابقه كقرار هذه
يعني اخر سؤال بماذا تبرر الحركه الطالبان
منعها للفتيات من التحق بالجامعات ومن
العمل في المنظمات غير الحكوميه
في اخر همم مقابله ظهرت فيها وزير التعليم
العالي الافغاني ندى محمد نديم قدم اربعه
تغيرات قاله هناك مهاجي على الفتيات في
الجامعات الحكوميه وغير الحكوميه وهذه
المهاجر يقطنها همم عدد من الفتيات من
المقاطعات الاخرى وهؤلاء
الفتياتنا الى هذه المهاج والى هذه
الجامعات من مقاطعه بعيده همم مع غير محرم
وبرر كذلك بان هناك لحد الان لم ينتهي همم
الاختلاط بين الجنسين بين الذكور والاناث
وقدم تبريرات قديمه جديده وهذه التمريرات
بشكل عام اا كان يجب على طالبان ان تتغلب
على هذه المشاكل سواء كانت اجتماعيه او
اقتصاديه او امنيه همم
نعم نعم طيب هو بالنسبه للمنظمات الحكوميه
ماذا قال ايضا بسبب يعني
وجود اختلاط بين الرجال والنساء هذا هو
السبب
لايقدم الخطاب الذي تم ارساله الى
المنظمات الدوليه والمحليه هناك تبريران
فقط في هذا الخطاب ما قراته في اللغه
الفارسيه التبرير الاول انه همم انه بسبب
تقديم شكاوى من المواطنين
والتبرير الثاني
العاملات والموظفات في هذه المنظمات كنا
لا يراعيين الحجاب الشرعيه بحسب هذا
الخطاب شكرا جزيلا لك عبد الله نادر مراسل
العربيه
مروه احدى الطالبات التي تاثرن بقرار
منعهن من التعليم كانت على بعد بضعه اشهر
فقط من ان تصبح اول امراه في عائلتها
الافغانيه تلتحق بالجامعه وبدلا من ذلك
تراقب بالم بينما يذهب شقيقها الى الجامعه
وهي لا
داخل هذا المكان
كبرت احلام
وقبرت اخرى في بلاد تعاني فيها النساء من
نيل حتى ابسط حقوقهم
اختيار زياده
لا استطيع ان اصف بالكلمات ما شعرت به في
اليوم الذي تلقيت فيه تلك الاخبار حتى لو
قرروا قطع رؤوس النساء لكان افضل من هذا
الحظر
خوف وياس ومستقبل مجهول
هكذا حياته خارج دائره الزمن بفعل قرار من
طالبان
اردت ان تحقق اختي اهدافها الى جانبي وان
تنجح وتمضي قدما رغم العديد من المشاكل
انا سعيده
لكن من ناحيه اخرى اشعر بالحزن
فسيكون لها مستقبل بائس مثلي
من الحياه العامه في افغانستان نهج تتبعه
طالبان دون اقتراس باضراره الكارثيه
الحاليه والمستقبليه في مواصله لاسلوبها
الدائم في تجهيل النساء
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه بعد اشتباكات
العنيفه بين الاكراد والشرطه الفرنسيه
العربيه
[موسيقى]
تطوراته متى تتارجح بين نقيضين دعوه
للتفاوض من هنا وتصعد ميداني المتواصل من
هناك ما يجعل التكهنات في مسارها امرا
صعبه اخر التطورات ما كشفت عنه مجله
نيوزليك الامريكيه التي قالت ان هناك مسار
عسكريا جديدا تخطط روسيا لتنفيذه خلال
الفتره المقبله في اخرها مجله نيوزويك
الامريكيه نقلت عن معهد دراسه الحرب في
واشنطن تقارير تفيد بان موسكو تضع اللمسات
الاخيره على هذا المسار الذي وصفته
بالاكثر خطوه
التقرير اكد هذه المره النابله روسيا
ستكون محطه مهمه في هذا المسار العسكري
الجديد فاضافت المجله ان زياده عدد القوات
الروسيه في بيلاروسيا هو جزء من خطه
الكريمه لتجديد غزو اوكرانيا وذكر المعهد
ان الرئيس البيلاروسيا الكسندر لوكيشنكو
اختبر الاستعداد القتالي لقوه بلاده ما
يثير شكوكا حول امكانيه مشاركه بين روسيا
مباشره في الحرب
ميدانيا يبدو ان الامور تسير نحو صدمات
اضافيه في ظل المسارات العسكريه الجديده
لكن هذا التطور لا يلغي الحل الديب
الخماسيه الذي عاد ليطفئ الى السطح مجددا
الرئيس روسيه قال ان بلاده مستعده للتفاوض
مع كل اطراف الصراع الاوكراني حلول مقبوله
وتابع قوته ان الامر يعود الاكياب
وحلفائها في موسكو لا ترفض التفاوض لكن هم
من يرفضون على حرب
كيف لم تتاخر في الرد على تصريحات الرئيس
الروسيه وجاء ذلك على لسان ميخائيل فضل
يكى مستشار الرئيس الاوكراني الذي اتهم
موسكو بالتنصل من المسؤوليه حيث دعى عبد
حسابه على تويتر الى العوده الى ارض
الواقع ملتهما روسيا بعدم الرغبه في
التفاوض ان دعواتها غير جديه
بالحديث عن الحلول المقبوله بوتن كانت
موسكو قد المحت في الكثير من المناسبات
الى شروط من اجل قبول التفاوض مع كلاب
وحلفائها وتتلخص فيه التوقف في عن داخل
اسلحه والاموال للجيش الاوكراني الاعتراف
بالمناطق التي ضمتها روسيا بعد العمليه
العسكريه استئناف الحوار على اساس
المتكافئ دون اجبار روسيا على تقديم
تناسولات
معي من موسكو مراسل العربيه عبد الجواد
الرشد عبد الجواد اهلا بك معنا هل هناك ما
يدعم في روسيا اي مؤشرات تدعم هذا التقرير
الامريكي عن مسار الحرب الجديد الذي يستعد
له بوتين في اوكرانيا
مساء الخير صهيب رسميا لا طبعا لا توجد اي
معلومات تتحدث حول مسار او تحويل طريقه
العمليه العسكريه الروسيه الخاصه في
الاراضي الاوكرانيه كل مخاوف الغرب
ومخاوفيه وقالقها مما يحدث ومما يمكن ان
يحدث هو يعتمد على تقارير غربيه حسب روايه
موسكو لكن طبعا ما اثار هذا الموضوع صهيب
كانت زياره الرئيس الروسي بوتين الى مينسك
طبعا مطلع هذا الاسبوع يوم الاثنين الماضي
طبعا الشراكه العسكريه التي يدور الحديث
عنها اليوم من روسيا وميسك كما صرحت
الخارجيه الروسيه
كما صرحت الخارجيه الروسيه يوم امسيه غير
متجهه لخدمه العمليه العسكريه في اوكرانيا
هي فقط طبعا عباره عن لصد اي هجوم محتمل
قد يطال مينسك او ايطالي الاراضي
البيلاروسيا وهي الحليفه الاستراتيجي
اول لموسكو طبعا بالعوده الى ملف والتقرير
الذي يتحدث عن الخطه الجديده كما نلاحظ
بان بعض المراقبين العسكريين في روسيا وهم
غير رسميين لكنهم يتحدثون عن ان قائد
العمليه العسكريه صروف كنسرجي اخترع
تكتيكات جديده لاضعاف القوات المسلحه
الاوكرانيه وهي جذبها نحو معارك طويله
ومعارك كما سموها طبعا معارك ام مرهقه
باعتبار ان المدفعيه الروسيه والطيران
تتفوق بمراحل اليوم على نظيرتها
الاوكرانيه بالاضافه الى ان المعدات
العسكريه الروسيه يزيد عددها عن بتسعه
مرات عن المعدات العسكريه
هذه الرسائل الحرب ولكن همم هناك رسائل
بين السطور في كلام الرئيس القديم همم
امكانيه التفاوض او الاستعداد
لتفاوض ماذا قال ايضا الرئيس الروسي في
حديثه للقناه الروسيه
صهيب بس هو كان صحيح بانها رسائل بين
السطور وموجهه طبعا للغرب بوتين تحدث عن
ثلاث ملفات رئيسيه الاولى طبعا بان موسكو
جاهزه للتفاوض على عكس يعني الغربيين
والشركاء لكيف وعدم جلديتهم في هذا
الموضوع راح يتحدث ووصف موقف الغرب
بالاستهزائي نوعا ما طبعا النقطه الثانيه
التي تحدث عنها بوتين بانه سيقوم باستهداف
جميع انظمه الدفاع الجوي التي تتصل
الاراضي الاوكرانيه من واشنطن وفي النقطه
الثالثه طبعا والتي تقرا جيدا بين السطور
وهي رساله واضحه للغرب بان موسكو مستمره
في العمليه العسكريه هي تبحث بشكل واضح
وصريح عن حمايه مصالحها وحمايه مواطنها
بالاضافه الى مواطن الدم بس والمناطق التي
اعلنت روسيا ضمها خلال الفتره الاخيره وهي
دانيه
مباشره من موسكو شكرا جزيلا
[موسيقى]
المدعيه العامه لباريس ان المتقاعد الذي
اعترف بقتلي ثلاثه اكراد في باريس قال انه
ذهب اولا الى بلده في ضاحيه ساندني
الشماليه للعاصمه باريس لارتكاب جرائم قتل
ضد اجانب فذكرت المدعيه العامه الفرنسيه
انه تخلى عن التوجه الى ضواحي باريس لقله
الموجودين وصعوبه اعاده ملئ السلاححه وانه
فضل تنفيذ الهجوم في منطقه مقتظه اضافه ان
الرجل البالغ من العمر 69 عاما اعترف بانه
يكن له كراهيه للاجانب حتى اصبحت حاله
مرضيه كما
[موسيقى]
العربيه رصدت اثار الشغب بين الجالي
الكرديه والشرطه الفرنسيه في باريس
متناقضان للحياه الفارسيه صفوف طويله لمن
ان ينتظرون الدخول الى سيرك الشتاء
التاريخي لمشاهده عروض متنوعه وعلى بعد
امطار سمح هدوء ما بعد العاصفه لسكان
الحيه والعابرين فيه بمعاينه الاضرار
سيارات قلبت او احرقت وواجهات زجاجيه
تحطمت جزئيا وغضب كردي تفجر بعد ان اقدم
يمني متطرف اقر بعنصريته على قتل ثلاثه
افراد وجرح ثلاثه اخرين صباح الجمعه اقر
المعتدي ايضا انه توجه صباح الجمعه الى
ضاحيه سند حيث اراد قتلى اكبر عدد من
المهاجرين لكن قله عدد الناس في الشارع
دفعته للعوده الى باريس حيث اقدم على
جريته الثلاثيه حصيله المواجهات واحد
وثلاثون شرطيا جرح وجرح متظاهر واحد ودعى
المسؤولون الاكراد الغاضبين الى الهدوء في
مقاله وزير العدل الفرنسي مطمئنا الاكراد
ان فرنسا كلها في عزاء وان دعمنا لكم ثابت
لا يتزعزع
هذا وخرج العشرات من الاكراد في مدينه
الحسكه السوريه في تظاهره ضد الهجوم الذي
تعرض له ابناء جليتهم في مدينه باريس
مطالبين الحكومه الفرنسيه
بمعاقبه الجميع
الاخير في باريس سنواصل المقاومه وسنواصل
كفاحنا انها حرب ضد شعبنا انهم لا
يستهدفوننا فقط في مناطق الكردستان
الاربعه ولكن ايضا في اوروبا يريدون ان
يموت شعبنا
الحسكه
لايصال رسالتنا للعالم اجمع وللحكومه
الفرنسيه ان الشعب الكردي يقاتل ضد
الحرمان نحن شعب مسالم ذبحنا في جميع
انحاء العالم حتى في باريس مدينه العلم
والحب والحريه نحن الشعب الكردي نطالب
الحكومه الفرنسيه بتقديم الجاني للعداله
[موسيقى]
بدايه الجائحه التي هزت العالم واوقفت
حركته على امتداد نحو عامين الوضع يبدو
مقلقا في الصين في ظل الاعتراف بارتفاع
الاصابات في مشهد شبيهم بخريف عن 2019
نحو مئتين 250 مليون اصابه بكرونا خلال 20
يوما رقم مخيف يعكس الانتشار السريع
للعدوى خلال هذه الفتره من السنه وهو رقم
يعادل 18% من سكان البلاد
اربعه اربعه سوق هذا الاسبوع افضل بكثير
من الاسبوع الماضي لقد بلغ ذروته في
الثانيه عشر من الشهر الجاري عند مصطفى
حوالي 240 الى 350 شخصا خارج المستشفى
لتلقي العلاج والان العدد يتراوح بين 240
و 200 250 كان الناس ينتظرون حوالي ثلاث
الى اربع ساعات الان يستغرق الامر حوالي
نصف ساعه
ومن الان فصاعدا لن يكون متاحا التعرف على
اعداد الاصابات في الصين بعد ما اعلنت
اللجنه التابعه للصحه الوطنيه في البلاد
التوقف عن نشر البيانات اليوميه الاصابات
وذلك دون تحديد السبب وراء هذا القرار
كانت الصين قد رفعت التدابير الصحيه صارمه
متعلقه بسياسه في الاسبوع الاول من شهر
ديسمبر الجاري وهو ما ادى الى الارتفاع
الكبير في عدد الاصابات وتحذيرات من موجه
اشد لمتحول اوميكرون الصين
عكس بقيه العلم لا حديثه في الصين الا عن
فيروس كورونا كمامات وفحوص المستشفيات تعج
بالمرضى والسلطات تحاول فرض رقابه على ما
ينشر عن الموضوع صور تذكر بايام بدايه
الجائحه
تقارير تتحدث عن 250 مليون اصابه في مختلف
مناطق البلاد خلال 20 يوما فقط ما يعادل
18 في المئه من السكان وفقا لتقدير داخلي
من كبار الصحه على سبيل المثال تواجه
المقاطعه الصناعيه في الصين اصابات مرتفعه
وصلت الى المليون يوميا ومن المتوقع ان
تتضاعفه وفق حكومه المقاطعه اعتقد ان
الوضع في المستشفى جيد بشكل عام من الرائع
ان نرى قسم الطوارئ يعمل على هذا النحو من
جهاتها توقعت حكومه مقاطعه في منشور على
وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي ان يصاب 80% من
سكانها اين يمثل نحو 36 مليون شخص
بالفيروس حتى مارس
الاحصاءات على صعيد البلاد غير مكتمله
بعدما توقفت لجنه الصحه الوطنيه عن
الابلاغ عن اعداد الاصابات مما يجعل من
الصعب تتبع الحالات مجموعه عالميه تعمل
على تتبع انتشار فيروس كورونا قالت ان
تفشل وباء في الصين ياتي بسبب سلالات
الفيروس التي انتشرت في انحاء العالم مع
عدم وجود علامات حتى الان على ظهور
متحولات جديده خطيره
بلال الوجداني العربيه
معنا من القاهره دكتور امجد الخولي رئيس
الفريق اللوائح الصحيه الدوليه في منظمه
الصحه العالميه دكتور اهلا بكم معنا في
اخبار الساعه من العربيه مليون اصابه
بكوفيت في تشاندي
الصينيه وتوقعات بزياده العدد للضعف الى
اي حد يجب ان نقلق من عوده كوفي
في البدايه مساء الخير
الحقيقه
الجائحه لم تنتهي بعده بالتالي متوقع
بالطبع حدوث بعض الموجات في دوله هنا او
دوله هناك ولكن المهم جدا هو حتى الان لا
توجد سريرات جديده لم تثبت حتى الان موجود
سلالات جديده الاجراءات الاحترازيه
المعتاده التي تتبعها جميعا على علم كبير
بها اللقاحات ما زالت فعاله ما نشهده في
الصين من من زياده حالات او الاعداد
الحالات في الفتره الاخيره الحقيقه كما
ذكر التقرير كان مجموعه من رفع الاجراءات
الاحترازيه التي طبقتها الصين الحقيقه
بصراحه شديده في البطن السابقه وبالتالي
ده انذار همم
البشريه جميعا لانه ما زالنا في الجائحه
ما زال الالتزام بهذه الاجراءات بالقواعد
الاساسيه من الاجراءات على الاقل لابد ان
نستمر الشيء ال- ال- المهم جدا الاعلان
عنه انه ما بالرغم من وجود اعداد كبيره
جدا من الحالات الا ان العادات الوافيات
ضئيله جدا هذا يعني ان الفيروس صحيح همم
سريع الانتشار بينتشر بشكل كبير بيسبب
اصابات كثيره ولكن اثره على الوفيات
والاصابات الخطيره اقل بكثير من الموجات
الاولى التي شاهدناها في الجراحه وبالتالي
لا يمكن ان المقارنه ما بين الوضع الحالي
ووضع بدايه الجياح ولكن لابد من الاستمرار
في اجراءاتنا خبر مبشر الدكتور امجد
اعطيتنا اياه يعني رغم هذه الاصابات
العاليه مليون اصابه يوميا حوالي 250 همم
مليون اصابه خلال 20 يوم همم هذا لن يجعل
الدول تتجه الى اغلاق الرحلات باتجاه
الصين من والى الصين او ربما الاقدار او
همم اغلاقات جديده
ونظام الصحه العالميه لا تدعو بهذا على
الاطلاق انه احنا بنتحدث عن جائحه اصاله
البشريه وجود دوله بيزداد فيها ليس معناه
وضع
اجراءات حظر او سواء تجاريه او سفر ما بين
المواطنين ما بيننا لكن المهم جدا
الشفافيه وده فرصه انه نظام سهل عالميه
بتدعو جميع الدول
الشفافيه في اعلان الارقام اعلان الحالات
والمشاركه بالعينات المساحات التاكد من
عدم وجود
علاج جديده سواء كان المصريين او غيرها من
الصلاه
الاكثر انتشارا في العالم هي في الالات ام
ميكرون او متحولات لها علاقه بهمكم
نعم طيب الدكتور امجد على ذكر البيانات
كان هناك اعلان اليوم على انه الصين
ستتوقف عن ذكر اعداد الاصابات اليوميه
انتم في منظمه الصحه العالميه كي هل انتم
قلقون من من هذا التكتم ربما او عدم
الاعلان عن اعداد الاصابات اليوميه في
الصين
وده ينطبق على كل دول العالم الحقيقه
لشفافيه واعلان الحالات وليست مجرد ارقام
ولكن اعلان الحالات الوضع الوبائي انتشار
الحياه الجغرافيه همم سمات الخاصه
بالحالات تتهورها ومعدلات اللي هو فيات
والاصابات الشديده كل هذه المعلومات
اساسيه لابد ان تتم بشفافيه ما بين جميع
الدول يعني النظاميه على اتصال وثيقه
الصين لتاكيد تبادل البيانات بشكل دوري
طيب دكتور امجد ذكرت في معرض الحديث انه
الموجه الحاليه في الصين والعداد الكبيره
من الاصابات الا انه اعداد الوفيات قليله
بسبب هذه الموجه الجديده ولكن هناك همم
بعض الاحاديث
على انه هذه الموجه او ال ال
الفايروس الموجود حاليا في الصين هو اخطر
من اوميكرون او سلاله همم متحوره من
اوميكرون اشد خطرا همم ماذا لديها منظمه
الصحه العالميه لتقول ما ما هي المعلومات
المتوفره حول المتحور المنتشر حاليا في
الصين
كما ذكرتهم المتحول ال- ال- المنتشر حاليا
في الصين هو متحول من متحولات همم
اوميكرون الحياه في في بعض ال- همم خصائص
تكون اكثر خطوره الى حد كبير بيستطيع
الانتشار بشكل اسرع همم حتى ما بين
الممنعين ولكن على الجانب الاخره كما ذكرت
من من قليل انه همم انتشاره سريع لكن
خطورته بتكون اقل وبالتالي همم ودي ميزه
بشكل عام انه طيب
خطوره انتقاله الى دول اخرى همم في الفتره
المقبله او خلال همم فصل الشتاء
الانتقال ورد بالطبع ولكن المهم هو كيف
تتعامل الدول مع هذه الامراض حاليا الدول
جميعها لديها بعض الاصابات وبالتالي وجود
مجرد ما بتظهر سلاله جديده بتنتشر في
العالم كله المهم قدره هذه الدول قدره
الدول العالم جميعها على التعامل واستمرار
الاجراءات سواء من الاجراءات الترصد
الاجراءات المخبريه
التحصين اللقاحات الحقيقه
كبيره جدا في تقليل عيب وشراسه المرض
شاهدنا انخفاضات كبيره سقف الاعداد
على ذكر اللقاحات هل همم ستكون هناك حاجه
لاخذ جرعه اضافيه الان من اللقاحات مع هذه
الاعداد الكبيره في الصين
ايه حتى الان لا لا ننصح بها اخذ اجراءات
اضافيه
اشخاص محددين الذين لديهم امراض تغتصب
المناعه الذين يثبت ان مناعته منخفضه بشكل
كبير حتى لو كان
حصولهم على اللقاحات من قبل ولكن اللقاء
بشكل عام جماعي كجرعاه ثالثه ورابعها
لحقيقه لا ينصح للجميع باستعمالها شكرا
جزيلا لك دكتور امجد الخولي رئيس فريق
اللوائح الصحيه الدوليه في منظمه الصحه
العالميه كنت معنا من القاهره
[موسيقى]
بعد قليل في اخبار الساعه عندما ياتي
الزائر الابيض كيف نحمي انفسنا في اوقات
التجمد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الولايات المتحده تخوض
معركه صعبه ضد الثلوج فالبلاد تواجه عاصفه
ثلجيه الجليديه قويه قادمه من القطب
الشمالي تعد الاقوى منذ حوالي اربعه عقود
عاصفه كلفت امريكا خسائر في الارواح
والممتلكات وتسببت في وفاه ما لا يقل عن
19 شخصا حتى الان كما ادت العاصفه الثلجيه
الى انقطاع الكهربائي عن اكثر من 700,000
شخص وبتت انظمه الطاقه تعاني بسبب زياده
الاستهلاك الاضرار مسك بشكل كبير رحلات
الطيران حيث ادت العاصفه الى الغائها اكثر
من
1300 رحله جويه في انحاء الولايات المتحده
وتاخر خمسه الاف وثلاث مئه رحله اخرى
[موسيقى]
من رونالدو
في الولايات المتحده معا حسينه مراسل
العربيه حسين اهلا بك معنا يعني عواصف
ثلجيه وبرد استثنائي في ربما اسوا عاصفه
تضرب الولايات المتحده منذ حوالي 40 سنه
ما الذي تمكنت من رصده حتى الان
تحيه لك صهيب انا هنا الان في مطار رونالد
ريجن في الحقيقه الاوضاع افضل بكثير من
اليومين السابقين اللذان يسبقان ليله
الذبله ليله عيد الميلاد المجيد من من نحو
والغاء لرحلات جويه يوم الجمعه من يوم
نتحدث هنا في مطار رونالدو
صغر المطار هو المطار المحاضره للعاصمه
واشنطن في مطارات اخرى على الوضع يختلف
نسيمه في المطارات الكبيره
الرحلات المتوجهه نحو الولايات الشماليه
التي ضربها همم هذا الانفجار القطبي كما
يوصف خاصه منطقه غرب ولايه نيويورك
وتحديدا ااه مدينه بافلو- جاورها الذي
تعرضت الى همم العاصفه الاسوء وهي وهنا
المفارقه ان هذه المدينه صهيب يا مدينه
مجهزه لمواجهه العواصف الكبيره لديهما
الادوات ولديهما الامكانيات لمواجهه كذا
عواصف ولكن مع ذلك هذه العاصفه كانت اقوى
من كل التجهيزات التي كانت سابقا نحن هنا
اذا سنتجول قليلا الاوضاع تبدو هادئه
اليوم مقارنه كما قلنا باليومين السابقين
حيث اضطر العديده من المسافرين الى البقاء
في المطار او همم حجز فنادق في منطقه
قريبه اليوم الرحلات كانت همم اسهل بسبب
طبعا تحسن الاجواء نوعا ما مقارنهم اليوم
على الصعيد الوطني تم الغاء همم نحو 1600
رحله وتم تاجيل همم نحو ثلاثه
رحله همم هنا في داخل المتحده همم سالنا
بعض الاشخاص هنا تحدثناهم طبعا هناك همم
حالات احباط الكثيرون هنا في الولايات
المتحده خلال هذه العطله للقضاء همم عط
عيد الميلاد ولا سينما ليله عيد الميلاد
ويوم عيد الميلاد العشاء والغداء مع
اقربائهم الكثير منهم اضطروا همم البقاء
في المطارات او بعضهم قرر يعني ان يستاجر
سياره ويسافر بالبر ولكن ايضا كان هناك
مخاطر بسبب الجديد الذي اصاب الطرقات في
العديد من الولايات هنا نسيمه في الولايات
الوسطى التي ايضا لم تضربها العاصفه
الثلجيه ولكن البرد القارس الذي ادى الى
ااه هطول الامطار جليديه والى تكون طبقه
جليديه على الطرق في العديد منها شكرا
جزيلا لك حسين الطود همم مباشره من مطار
رونالدو في العاصمه
الثلوج اذا عطلت ايضا مختلفه جوانب الحياه
في كندا ففي مدينه اونتاريو حصلت العاصفه
الثلجيه السكان وعطلت حركه التنقل
[موسيقى]
وبينما تجمد هذه العواصف الثلجيه الحياه
في بقاع كثيره من العالم نشرات المنظمات
النصائح حول كيفيه حمايه انفسنا في مثل
هذه الاوقات متابعه
[موسيقى]
اذا نهايه العام تقترب وفي فقرتنا اليوميه
حتى نهايه هذا العام وقفه الان مع ابرز
الاحداث التي شهدها شهر يونيو من سنه 2012
[تصفيق]
اجدمات
[موسيقى]
كان بقاء الكتله الصدريه
عائقا امام تشكيل الحكومه
وكل نواب الكتله زادهم الله شرفا
مستعدون للاستقاله
[موسيقى]
اسمه بلاي ستيشن
الساعه انتهت هذا تذكير بابرزي اخبارها
رغم التمديدات والتحضيرات طالبا تتحدي منع
الفتيات من التعليم والعمل وتقول لو القوا
علينا قنبله ذريه لن نتراجع
في العلن فوت ان يخرج ورقه التفاوض وفي
السر يخطط لمسار عسكري جديد اكثر خطوره في
اوكرانيا
منها واليها شبح كورونا يعود للصين ويهدد
بموجه واسعه تضرب مئات الملايين
ومخاوف من سيناريو 2019
عواصف ثلجيه قاسيه تجمد الحياه في امريكا
كندا ودول اوروبيه وتتسبب في حاله فوضى في
المطر
شكرا لكم على كرم المشاهده
[موسيقى]